gergen latitude 47 degrés nord longitude
4 degrés est un petit village niché au
coeur de la vallée de l'ouche où l'on
arrive par la route sinueuse qui grimpe
de pont de pany vous ne connaissez pas
eh bien vous devriez car gerriet y est
désormais le centre géographique de
notre nouvelle grande région et de
mémoire de gergoy on n'avait jamais
entendu parler de ça je suis pas pensé
une seconde à m c'est un honneur pour
nous voilà on est là nous permettra de
faire connaître un peu le village les
gens ils sont curieux allons que je
pense qu'il y aura beaucoup de gens qui
me rend morts enfin on espère du coup ce
matin au village c'était le principal
sujet de discussion vous savez pourquoi
on est là aujourd'hui moi je me doute un
petit peu parce que j'ai du journal
parce que j'ai recueillis c'est le
centre des bruins c'est pour ça que la
bourgogne franche comté à de la boue
mais transposé oh là là ça va faire
parler un peu du recueil
mais d'un autre côté c'est pas bien
parce que là on est bien quand on parle
pas de nous les gens ne viennent pas
nous embêter
oui on comprend bien monsieur mais
maintenant tout le monde le sait il faut
assumer
nous donne un privilège il faut que le
en pratique nous soit lignes de cette
considération
que nous fait un bon choix que ce soit
en bourgogne le centre plutôt qu'en
franche comté sûr ce serait bien si
c'est vraiment un bon show mais bon
toujours est il bah si c'est dur ça ben
c'est comme ça on va pas faire
alors pour la géographie c'est fait
reste à définir la capitale est
évidemment le nom des habitants robben
pour meneau je vois pas non franchement
c'est compliqué hier c'est bourgui
francs contre encore aux bourguignons